Hi I'm Rick Stengel. I'm the editor of Time Magazine and I am here with Bill Gates...
...to talk about his story for Time this week.
Welcome Bill.
Thank you.
It's all about your big idea of creative capitalism. I'd love you to tell our readers...
...what the heck creative capitalism is.
Well, capitalism has done a great job for the people who are well-off.
But if we look at the disparity between the poorest and the rest of the world, that gap is growing.
And so the question is, can we take some of the caring and innovation power, the resources...
...of corporations and get them to focus more of that on the needs of the poorest?
And it's very timely, because whether it's breakthroughs in medicine...
...or using cellphones in creative ways,...
...new forms of banking, food with better nutrition,...
...there are clearly some things that these large companies with their...
...great resources and their innovation power,...
...if we get them to apply that more significantly for those with the most need,...
...that we can reduce impoverishment far faster than simply relying on government alone.